So
today we're going to talk about you and
I find that tremendously entertaining.
Um,
uh,
I,
I'm not sure I ever,
I've ever read anyone is intelligent as
you'll accept,
maybe need shift.
Um,
it's funny,
he's accused of many things such as
starting a new religion by some rather
unscrupulous biographers.
But what he did was actually far more
radical than anything he's ever been
accused of it.
One other thing I should tell you too is
young as often been accused of Anti
Semitism,
but one of the things that came to light
in last year was that he was working as
an agent for the American government
during World War II and frequently set
updates on Hitler psychological
condition to the highest levels of the
American government.
He never told anybody about that.
So.
So,
you know,
that's a little hard on all accusations
of antisemitism,
I think,
which I've never thought had held any
merit anyways.
So young.
He was a strange guy in many ways,
extraordinarily imaginative.
He could get lost in daydreams and was a
tremendously powerful visualizer.
And a lot of what he discovered
was a consequence of engaging in
longterm,
elaborated and fantasies and in these
fantasies he could have conversations
with figures of his imagination and
communicate with them.
I had a client at one point who was a
very prolific dreamer and she can talk
to her characters in your dreams and ask
them what they meant symbolically and
they would tell her that was really
something.
I've only seen one person who who was
capable of doing that.
She was.
I don't know if it helped her that much
in the final analysis,
but she couldn't do it.
And young was very,
very interested in the depths of the
human imagination.
Now his
body of work
can be viewed as an amalgam of many
things,
but he.
He had deep knowledge of Latin and Greek
and he'd studied l chemical manuscripts
for many,
many years as an older man.
So he was very interested in the
emergence of the idea of science from
what he considered the collective
imagination.
But in many ways his primary modern
intellectual influences.
I would say we're Nietzsche and Freud
and you'll really set out some somewhat
like Piaget too,
address the gap between religion and
science,
but he did it for different reasons than
piaget.
You'll took niches,
comments about the death of God very
seriously,
and one of the things need shape
predicted at the end of the 19th century
was that there were going to be two
major consequences of the collapse of
formal religious belief.
He believed that that would lead people
to a morally relativistic condition that
would prove psychologically intolerable.
Because if you adopt a morally
relativist position and you take it to
its final conclusion,
then everything is of equal value and
there's no gradient between things.
There's no better,
no worse.
And in the final analysis,
you might say,
well,
there's no good and there's no evil.
And the problem with that is you can
actually orient yourself in a world that
has those properties.
Because in order to act as we've already
talked about with regards to the
cybernetic models,
you have to be aiming at something
that's better than what you have now.
Or there's no reason to expend the
energy.
And so you need the gradient,
you need a value differentiation in
order to act and niches.
Analysis was predicated on the idea that
if the value hierarchy collapsed well,
not only would people not be motivated
to do anything anymore,
but they would also be extraordinarily
confused and depressed because the value
would go out of their life and the
consequence of that would be that they
would become somewhat nihilistic or
maybe absolutely nihilistic or that they
would turn to ideological rigid
ideological systems as a replacement.
Now,
what niche him
offered as an alternative to that was
that human beings could create their own
values,
and so his idea was that the superman,
the overmanned,
depending on how you look at it,
would be the person who was capable of
transcending the value list universe
that the decline of religion had left
with us and creating their own values as
a conscious act.
The problem with that is that it isn't
obvious that you can create your own
values as a conscious act because it's
not obvious that values are consciously
create it,
and I think this is why the
psychoanalysts had so much to add to the
philosophical debate,
at least the philosophical debate that
developed to the point of Nietzsche's
observations.
When Freud entered the scene,
the idea of the unconscious was in the
air,
but Freud formalized it to a much
greater degree than anyone else had,
and Freud's theory really is deeply
biological.
You know his,
his.
It's biological,
it's social as well,
but his proposition proposition that
there is an id is fundamentally the
proposition that you're not necessarily
your consciousness for sure is not the
master in its own house.
Now,
I think part of the reason that people
like to go after Freud,
there's a variety of reasons,
but one of them is that modern people
basically accept radical Freud and
presuppositions more or less as givens.
Now you know,
and so if you're a brilliant thinker and
your thought permeates the society to
the point where your most radical
propositions are accepted by everyone,
all of it's really left or your errors,
and so it's easy to concentrate on
Freud's errors because we've already
digested everything he had to say.
That was particularly profound.
I mean,
I don't imagine perhaps I'm wrong,
but I don't imagine that there's anyone
in this room to whom the news that many
of your motivations aren't conscious
comes as a surprise.
I mean,
even psychologists have admitted that in
the last 20 years,
you know,
I mean,
they talk about the cognitive
unconscious with which I think is a real
slight of hand maneuver to stop them
from having to Credit Freud with his
discoveries.
And I also think that Freud's notion of
the unconscious is far more
sophisticated than the cognitive
scientists notion because Freud viewed
the unconscious as a place that was
basically populated by fragmented
personalities.
Not cognitive schemes of one form or
another.
Not Processes,
but things that were like living beings.
And you know,
when you think,
well,
are there living beings in your
unconscious and the answer to that is,
well,
are you alive or not?
And you're alive.
So you're composed of living
subcomponents and they're not machines,
or at least not in any way that we
understand machines.
They're fragmentary,
subpersonalities,
and each of them have their own
worldview and rationalizations and
emotional structure and goals.
And so that's why when you get hungry,
you see the world through the eyes of a
hungry person and you think thoughts
about food and your emotional reactions
depend on whether food is available or
whether it isn't,
and maybe whether or not the food you
want is available and whether it isn't
and you know,
that that's nature,
so to speak,
imposing its necessities on you as a
living being.
And for Freud,
that was the end and Freud thought of
the Ed really as something that was
primordial and primitive and he and,
and,
and that's one of the things that really
separated him from you.
And I think young is much more accurate
from,
uh,
from the perspective of evolutionary
psychology.
In fact,
I think he's radically underestimated as
a thinker whose thought was unbelievably
deeply grounded in biology and like
young was a remarkable person because
his notion of history and the
relationship between history and the
human psyche,
what covered spans time that we're
really,
until modern historians and evolutionary
psychologist started to talk about deep
time and the fact that you know,
the entire 4 billion year history of the
world is in some sense relevant to us
talk to us as beings or at least the 3
billion,
three point 5 billion year history that
there's been life on the planet.
Ancient history for European
philosophers was like 500 to 2000 years
ago and young thought way past that way
back farther than that and started to
take into serious account the fact that
are the origins of our psyche.
The ground of our psyche is deeply
biological and that it's an emergent
property.
So for Freud,
Freud's idea of the unconscious is
somewhat difficult to understand because
there's sort of two elements to it.
There's the ID,
which is the source of primordial
motivation and Freud concentrated mostly
on aggression and sexuality.
And the reason he concentrated on those
two,
although we concentrated on what he
called the death instinct later in his
life,
the reason he concentrated on those two
primarily wasn't because he regarded
them necessarily as the most compelling
of motivations,
but he regarded those motivations as the
ones that were most difficult for most
people to integrate successfully into
the social world.
So he thought that they were most likely
to be repressed and therefore under
developed and immature.
And I think that's.
I think that's a reasonable proposition.
I think that modern people would have to
add eating to that because since the
time of Freud we've gone,
I would say from a high proportion of
sexually related pathologies to a very,
very high proportion of eating related
pathologies.
But that's in some sense beside the
point.
So that's one part of the Freudian
unconscious,
sort of an implicit unconscious.
Then the other part of the Freudian
unconscious is those things that have
happened to you that you've repressed
because you don't like what they imply.
And you know,
those are very different kinds of
unconscious because one of them is
dependent on your experience.
And the other isn't,
and you could think of young actually as
a,
a deep archeologist of the ID
and Freud,
Freud thought about the and sort of
primordial terms.
So his,
his angry id would be,
you know,
like a beast that's out of control.
But you
recognize that the unconscious was far
more sophisticated in many ways than the
conscious parts of your being and that
it guided your adaptation in ways that
you didn't understand
and that those,
the ways in which had guarded your
adaptation and structured your
understanding,
we're universal hands,
biological and
far more sophisticated than a somewhat
primordial notion of biological drive
might indicate.
So
one of the things that you might
consider,
for example,
is that from the union perspective,
a lot of the forces that ancient people
consider diabetes.
We're
personified representations of
instinctual systems.
So,
hey,
here's a way of thinking about it,
and this is the way of thinking about
the collective unconscious,
which is humans in some sense,
young's replacement term for the fraud
and ID.
So Mars,
for example,
is the god of war,
Roman God of war.
And you might say,
well,
what does it mean for there to be a god
of war?
And the answer or Venus is the god of
love actually,
of,
of sexual attraction,
more particularly,
or have sexual possession,
which is even a better way of thinking
about it.
And you say,
well,
why would people conceptualize of those
phenomena as gods?
The Greek set,
for example,
that human beings were the play things
of the gods.
No,
that's what Shakespeare.
I'm sorry,
that was Shakespeare who said that?
Well,
here's one way of thinking about it.
What's older you or aggression?
Now answer to that is,
well,
you're 23 and the system that mediates
biological aggression in mammals and
their progenitors is tens of millions of
years old and if you think you control
it rather than the other way around,
you're diluted about your central
nature.
Part of it,
part of it is that you don't control it
at all.
What happens is that you never go
anywhere where you need to use it.
And so one of the things that happens to
soldiers in war time,
for example,
is they go somewhere where they could
use it and out it comes and the
consequence of its emergencies,
so traumatic that they develop
posttraumatic stress disorder because
they observe themselves doing things
that are hyper aggressive that they
could have never imagined that someone
like them could have manifested.
And then you think,
well,
what about Venus as a goddess?
Well,
if you fall in love with someone
who,
who
is that a choice?
It doesn't look like a choice.
If it's a choice,
it's often an incredibly self
destructive and idiotic choice and it's
often one that ruins people's entire
lives.
It's more like a state of possession and
then you might say,
well,
possession by what?
Well,
it's a dynamic living system and it's
also immortal in some sense,
which is another reason why
conceptualizing it as a daddy makes
sense,
mean the phenomena of love,
which is the manifestation of our
complex biological system,
will be alarm long,
will be around long after you're gone
and was there long before you showed up.
And when it manifests itself,
so to speak within you,
you're possessed by it and you do its
bidding and you may do its bidding
despite what you most deeply want.
You know,
modern people tend to think that the
conscious parts of their brain that say,
or let's say the more newly evolved
elements of their brain,
because we don't actually know what the
relationship is between consciousness
and the newly developed parts of the
brain.
The assumption is often made that the
reason we're conscious is because we've
developed a very spectacular cortical
cap,
but consciousness appears to be far
older than that.
So that's an erroneous assumption.
But we do tend to believe that the most
complex and sophisticated parts of our
brain are the cortical cap,
the complex cortical cap that's quite
enlarged in human beings relative to our
body size because it's the most.
It's the.
It's the newest systems and it's also
part of the systems that allow us to do
such things as communicate with language
and think in abstract symbols.
But there's a different way of thinking
about this from a biological
perspective,
and that is what makes you think the
newest system is the most sophisticated
one.
Why don't you assume that the oldest
system is the most sophisticated one
because it's been around for a while.
For example,
the mechanism in in your neurological,
the mechanism that underlies your
conception of your relationship to the
dominance hierarchy,
for example,
is at least 300 million years old and
the reason it's lasted 300 million years
is because it knows what it's doing
as far older than your parts of the
brain that make you conscious in the
specifically human way and it's so
deeply embedded in your brain in some
sense that you have almost no voluntary
control over it.
And that's why,
for example,
one of the things that happens to people
who are depressed is that the system
that reports their dominance,
dominance status
reports that they're low.
Now,
sometimes that's true because they're
not depressed.
They just have an awful life and they're
actually at the bottom of the dominance
hierarchy.
And that's not the same as being
depressed,
but sometimes it malfunctioned,
so someone who's competent and well
situated in life and who appears to have
everything that a person could possibly
desire in order to have a decent and
meaningful and positive life are still
catastrophic,
really depressed,
and what seems to happen in those
circumstances is that the dominance
counter for one reason or another,
is acting as if they're incredibly low
status when they're in fact not.
And I think that's a good definition of
clinical depression.
I also think that part of the reason
that there's mixed results with regards
to antidepressant trials is because
antidepressants don't help you if you're
at the bottom of the dominance
hierarchy.
Oh,
how good they.
You're not depressed.
You just have a terrible life that is
not the same thing and they need to be
carefully distinguished.
Because if you're unemployed and you're
facing the loss of your home and maybe
your partner's going to leave you and
your children hate you,
an antidepressant is very unlikely to
fix that.
Now to the degree that misbehavior on
your part called caused by impulsivity
and increased aggression and decreased
mood because of your reaction to that
circumstances is making it worse than
the antidepressant might help you and
maybe the antidepressant will help you
regain enough cognitive control so that
you can plan your way out of the
situation,
but as a medication in and of itself,
there's no possible way it can lift you
out of those often catastrophic,
complex and disintegrating
circumstances.
Whereas if your life is fine but you
feel terrible,
well,
it's much more likely that an
antidepressant can help with that
because in some sense,
what it's going to do is to readjust
your dominance,
the reporting of your dominance counter,
so to speak,
to the level that's appropriate for your
level of competence,
which is really what you want.
You know,
people say you should have high self
esteem.
I would say idiot say that you should
have high self esteem.
It's a.
it's an unbelievably corrupt construct
in many ways because it's actually very,
very highly correlated with baseline
levels of neuroticism negatively,
which is a fundamental personality
traits and baseline levels of
extroversion,
so someone with lower self esteem is
generally someone who's introverted and
has high levels of negative emotion.
It's a trait like phenomena.
It isn't clear at all that calling that
low self esteem has any utility
whatsoever,
but then you also might ask yourself,
well,
how much self esteem should you have?
Well,
that's a very complex question because
you can clearly have way too much.
That's what would make you a narcissist.
So I would say your self esteem should
be roughly equivalent to the esteem in
which your held by members of your
society.
You know your family and your society
because they're judging you,
at least in part on your competence and
you shouldn't think that you're more
competent than you are and you shouldn't
think that you're less competent than
you are.
You should think that you're as
competent as you are and sometimes that
means you're not competent at all
because you don't know what you're doing
and sometimes it means that you're quite
competent.
Now,
I think it's complicated by the fact
that you should also regard yourself not
only as who you are,
but as who you could be.
You know,
and so if you're of lowly dominant
status,
which for example in some sense you guys
are because you're young and you're
starting your lives,
the fact that there's a lot of potential
that you still are able to manifest
should tilt the self assessment balance
in your favor to a fair degree.
So
anyway,
so yoga was very interested in the
depths of the psyche and hit.
For him.
The unconscious wasn't a repository of
repressed experiences and it wasn't a
repository of underdeveloped and
irritated biological systems.
It was instead the underlying structure
of consciousness itself.
So you believe that human experience at
as it's consciously manifested,
was structured by underlying
patterns of behavior that were specific
and unique to to the,
to the human,
to human kind.
Although shared to some degree with
other animals and then on top of that a
realm of images stick and symbolic
representation,
that in part was
a consequence of representation of those
underlying behaviors.
So here's the way of thinking about it.
We act in a human way,
whatever that means,
and we'd been acting in a human way for
as long as there's been human beings and
we've been acting in a mammalian way for
as long as there's been mammals.
Now,
human beings are quite peculiar
creatures because not only do we act,
we also watch ourselves act and we
represent those actions and you unbelief
that as a consequence of
us manifesting
a specific set of typically human
behaviors over hundreds of thousands or
perhaps millions of years.
We also evolved the cognitive apparatus
that was capable of representing those
patterns of behavior and that cognitive
apparatus expressed the representations
of those fundamental patterns of
behavior in images,
stick and symbolic form,
and the basic images to can.
Symbolic form is something like drama.
Now,
why would that be?
Well,
it's.
It's obvious in some sense.
What is drama?
Drama is the representation,
the abstract representation of patterns
of behavior.
That's what you do when you go to a
movie,
you watch people manifest their
characteristic behaviors and then you
might know that there's.
Well,
there's characteristic
Kwanzaa,
unique of behavior that are portrayed in
drama.
So for example,
there's the bad guy and he wears the
black hat,
know a cowboy movie,
and whenever you go to a movie,
it's pretty clear to you right away who
the good guys are and the bad guys are,
and you accept the distinction between
good and bad guys as an a priority
acceptable distinction.
So you would say,
well,
that's the action of an archetype.
What underlies that is the archetypal
story of the hostile brothers and
hostile brothers,
for example,
or Cain and Abel,
which is the story of Cain and Abel in
Genesis,
by the way,
is really the second story that that's
in that origin myth,
and it's the first story about real
human beings,
right?
Because Adam and eve,
so to speak,
we're created by God.
Whereas Cain and Abel were born,
the first brothers.
Well,
what happened?
one of them became insanely jealous of
the other and murdered him,
so that's a pretty harsh story when you
think that you know,
the,
the monotheistic religions of,
of the West,
roughly speaking,
put as one of their foundational
stories.
The idea that there is a twin pair of
forces operating the human psyche that
can be conceptualized as brothers who
are murderously opposed to one another.
It's like
that's part of the reason why that story
hasn't disappeared.
It's so powerful.
It's so shocking.
It's so powerful that it can't
disappear,
and the reason for that is that it's
true in a sense.
It's true.
Like it's true that a reasonable drama,
not all of them obviously,
but a large proportion of them has a bad
guy and a good guy.
And then you might say,
well,
what would the archetypes be?
Well,
the archetypes would be the ultimate
good guy and the ultimate bad guy,
and there's representations of the
ultimate good guy in the ultimate bad
guy.
Young was very influenced by
Christianity and part of the reason for
that is that he grew up in a state that
was Protestant,
primarily Christian and a number of his
immediate ancestors were pastors,
so he grew up in an atmosphere that was
pretty saturated by religious ideas and
so a lot of his thinking was heavily
influenced by Christianity.
So one of the things he pointed out was
that just like Cain and Abel who are
archetypes in a sense,
they're archetypes of the.
They're the Old Testament version of
archetypes of the hostile brothers,
Christ and Satan.
Our archetypes and the reason they're
archetypes is because virtually by
definition,
the satanic symbol,
so to speak,
is a representation of symbolic
representation of everything that's
terrible about human beings.
It's an archetype.
You can't imagine anything worse than
that,
so it's like a limit case.
And then when you go to a movie and you
see bad guys,
you can think of them as partial
approximations of the archetype.
Or you can think about them as the
archetype.
Differentiated in a manner that makes
exposure to the archetype fresh and
interesting because you just don't want
to go and see the same old bad guy over
and over and over.
You want to explore the entire complex
behavioral and representational system
of the archetype of the,
of evil in every conceivable situation.
And in the same way you want to explore
the archetype of good and the reason you
want to do that in principle,
depending on your motivations,
is to control the influence of the
factors that underlie the negative
archetype in your life.
And to manifest the factors that
underlie the positive archetype.
And that's why you hope for the good
guy.
It's also why generally speaking in a
drama,
you embody that good guy while you're
watching the movie.
So I can give you an example of this.
So
one of the things I learned to do with
my son when I took them to movies
because when he was a little guy,
I took him to fairly intense movies and
uh,
sometimes too intense,
but I'm.
One of the things I taught him when he
was afraid was keep your eye on the
hero,
not,
don't be afraid or it's not real.
It's like
you could easily make a case that had
movie is more real than normal life.
Why would you watch it otherwise?
What a movie is his normal life stripped
of everything that's trivial.
So if you strip a representation of
everything that's trivial,
what makes you think that isn't more
real?
So is fiction more real than life?
Well,
is abstraction more real than reality?
It certainly is.
In many cases.
I mean there are people who believe,
for example,
that mathematical representations are
are the most real of phenomena.
They certainly,
if you're a very powerful mathematician,
they certainly become.
Or if your society is very powerful
mathematically,
it certainly gives you a tremendous
amount of control over your environment.
So the idea that abstractions aren't
real is that's a silly idea and the idea
that fiction isn't real,
it all that indicates is a confusion
about what constitutes real
movie as a representation of
characteristic behavioral patterns
extending across time.
And it can be a more or less useful,
accurate
distillation of those representations.
And generally what we assume is that the
greater the fictional representation
because we make a distinction between
great fictional representations and you
know,
second rate fictional representations.
So Shakespeare,
for example,
is a master at exploring the contours,
the archetype in a complex,
realistic and useful manner.
Now you'll also believe so that there
were these patterns of behavior and they
would constitute the typical behavioral
patterns of Human Beings.
And then we evolved a system of
representations of those patterns and
that would,
would enable us to understand the
patterns in a way that other animals
can't because we're self conscious,
right?
So what does it mean to be self
conscious?
It doesn't just mean that you know that
you exist as a separate entity.
It's not just a state of conscious
awareness,
it's a knowledge condition you have at
your fingertips.
A very large representational storehouse
of abstract knowledge about what human
beings are like.
And that's developed over tens of
thousands of years,
right?
It's a collective activity.
The generation of all these stories we
tell about each other.
I mean,
we have ancient stories.
The oldest stories we have,
by the way,
are Mesopotamian stories far as I know,
and the oldest Mesopotamian story,
or one of the oldest Mesopotamian
stories we have is a hero story where
the,
the God Marduk
fights a great dragon and cuts her into
pieces and makes the world and you might
think,
well,
what the Mesopotamians you know,
what do you mean the world's created
over the pieces of a great dragon?
Well,
it's,
it's a Piagetian idea with a bit of
narrative complexity added to it.
It's like,
well,
how do you create the world?
Well,
you confront the unknown and you
transform it into the known or you
confront unexplored territory and you
transform it into explored territory.
And then you might say,
well,
what exactly is the unknown?
Or what exactly is unexplored territory?
And as scientists would say,
well,
you know,
if you walk out in the field that you've
never been in before,
there's soil and material elements and
that's what's really there.
But that isn't exactly what's really
there.
It depends on your timeframe.
So one of the things I could say about
that,
for example,
is that if you wander outside the
boundaries of your knowledge,
if you wandered outside the boundaries
of your territory when you were an
animal or when you were a more archaic
human being,
the probability that you are going to
run into something that was going to
tear you apart and eat you was extremely
high.
And so then I could say,
well,
the fundamental nature of the unknown is
that which tears you apart in each you
and you might think,
well,
is that what sort of reality is that?
And I would say,
you know,
how you hear evolutionary psychologists
talk sometimes.
The fact that we evolved on the African
Veldt and now our nervous systems are
sort of adapted for that primordial
environment and not really for the
modern environment.
And so there's a mismatch between us in
the modern world.
It's like I,
I think that's an absolutely
reprehensible theory,
partly because we didn't just evolve on
the velt.
We've been evolving for a very long
time.
We spent a lot more time in trees,
for example,
than we did on the Veldt and while we
were spending time in trees,
a lot of us were eaten by snakes,
for example,
and so that's another reason why the the
unknown itself is represented as this
terrible predatory reptilian beast,
and then the human being is represented
as that which or the conscious element
of the human being which is represented
by the Mesopotamians as a god,
the highest God actually in the
hierarchy of Gods,
which was a brilliant method,
Mesopotamian realization because the
Mesopotamians basically concluded in
their drama,
their religious drama,
that the highest faculty of the human
being was the capacity to consciously
attend to the unknown and to make
something new out of it.
Well,
that's a Piagetian idea,
right?
That's exactly what piaget was talking
about when he talked about the necessity
of comprehending knowledge as a process
rather than as a collection of fact.
It's a process.
What's the process?
Confront what you don't understand.
Boldly go where no one has ever gone,
right?
I mean Star Trek.
That's where a systematizing minds get
their mythology.
You know?
It's rife with mythology and it's
initial statement is a mythological
statement and it's a statement of the
eternal explorer and that's an
archetypal idea and you know,
you might say,
well,
are you still threatened by those
terrible things that threatened your
ancestors on the Veldt?
And normally people would say,
well no,
because there are no lions,
but that's because they don't get the
categories right.
Lion is a subcategory of unknown
horrible thing and you guys are
surrounded by unknown horrible things
just like people have always been
surrounded by unknown horrible things,
so because you're just as prone to
disease,
not quite as prone,
but fundamentally you're a finite being
and there's things everywhere that act
in a predatory manner,
in relationship to you and you will die.
And so the idea that the material
conditions of our environment have
changed in a qualitative manner since
the time we spent on the belt is an.
It's an error of category.
The mythological categories of our
categories that represent environmental
entities,
so to speak,
some of which are social that have
existed for vast stretches of time and
which exceed our capacity to detect.
With our census,
so one representation for example is the
great father or the wise old man and the
wise old man of the great father is a
representation of the dominance
hierarchy.
Now the problem with the dominance
hierarchy is you can't see it,
but it's there.
It's really there and then figures like
the great mother,
especially the terror because most of
the archetypal figures come in pairs a
positive element and a negative element
and that's because virtually everything
that manifests itself to you in a
complex environment,
if you're living being takes with one
hand and gives with the other,
you know,
so nature is benevolent and kind and
wise and the source of all new knowledge
and also cancer and malarial mosquitoes
and the tetsy fly and the Guinea worm
and all these things that are horrifying
and destructive beyond belief and you're
stuck with both and then society.
We talked about this before.
That's the great father.
On the one hand here you are
benevolently protected by your social
surround.
On the other hand,
social structures tend towards tyranny
and authoritarianism and they'll press
the individuals within them at the same
time that they sustain their
development,
and so that's a dichotomous archetype
and then there's the individual who's on
the one hand a remarkable and wonderful
creature and on the other hand,
someone who's capable of atrocities like
those,
the characterized the auctions of many
millions of people in the 20th century.
Those are all archetypes.
There are more archetypes than that,
like the archetype of the predatory rep
tail with something to offer,
which is essentially a dragon is the
most fundamental archetipal
representation.
You found that representation in l
chemical manuscripts mostly in the form
of the Earl burls,
which is a snake that eats its own tail
and it's a symbol of matter and spirit
in union because the snake is sort of
matter and the wings on the snake,
the dragon make it spirit.
So it's like the fundamental elements of
reality or matter in spirit in some kind
of conjoined,
um,
state.
And the fundamental task of the human
being is to come to terms with the
nature of that unknown thing.
Now,
think about it this way.
Well,
why would ancient people represent the
unknown as such as a Reptilian self
contained reptilian form that was both
spiritual and Matt and material?
Well,
here's the reason.
First the unknown is dangerous and you
could be at spray so you better have
that representation at hand and then you
might ask,
well,
is that really the unknown?
And then I would say,
well,
it depends absolutely on what you mean
by really from a Darwinian perspective,
that was the best way to conceptualize
the unknown.
And then you might say,
well that doesn't make it real,
and then I might say,
you're,
are you sure about that?
Is there anything more real than than
representations derived from Darwinian?
The darwinists would say,
no.
Okay,
so why does it matter in spirit?
Why is it weighing in and on the ground
at the same time?
Well,
this is.
You can also understand this from a phd
and perspective and so that is because
when you encounter the unknown,
you separate the material world in the
spiritual world and the spiritual
wilderness is the psychological world
and so what you're doing,
when you encounter the unknown,
as you parse some of it up into the
world and you incorporate other elements
of it into yourself and the best way to
think about that,
I think from a conceptual perspective so
it becomes more understandable,
is that what you encounter when you
encounter the unknown is patterned
information and you take some of that
pattern and information into yourself.
Even by doing something as simple as
gripping something you want to pick up
because you're imitating the pattern of
the thing that you want to pick up.
And that's how you're transforming it.
Structure into an element of your being.
And so when you're exploring the
unknown,
it's constructivist idea.
You're simultaneously constructing the
world and constructing yourself,
and thus the inference is the unknown is
made out of that which can be parsed out
into psyche and matter.
And it's dangerous.
So it's a perfectly reasonable
representation.
And that's why it won't go away.
So Young's fundamental contribution,
I would say is the is his analysis of
hero mythology.
And I would say that's the fundamental
element of his thinking.
Now,
the relationship between that and Nisha
is fundamentally this Nicha believed
that once the religious systems
collapsed,
we would have to consciously produce our
new set of values.
But young believed that the psyche was
the source of all value and the so that
it wasn't a matter of creating new
values.
It was a matter of discovering the
values that were already lying dormant
and implicit within us.
So,
and the next thing I would say about
that is,
you all know this,
you just don't know you know it.
And so one of the reasons to be to be
educated from a literary and historical
perspective is that you can come to
understand what you already know because
if you don't understand it,
then there's an element of your being
the element that knows it and acts it
out.
And there's another element which is
sort of you as a personality that are
completely at odds with one another,
and that makes you weak.
It's it makes you something that's
divided within itself.
Now you're doing everything you can as a
general rule to incorporate this
information now for a long time.
It seems as if as long as we acted it
out and represented it symbolically and
didn't argue about the assumptions,
it was more or less okay,
but we're past that now and in order for
us to benefit from the same protective
structures that our ancestors benefited
from,
we now have to understand what they mean
consciously.
And that's really what young was up to.
What he was really trying to do was to
resurrect deep religious representations
from the dead,
so to speak,
and to make them conscious so people
could align themselves with them again.
Now I'm going to show you something
that's related to that.
All right,
now.
So we're going to show you something
from Pinocchio.
Now,
this is an initiation ritual.
It's a journey to the depths,
so it's journey to the underworld.
It's the consequence of a collapse.
In previous personality and the
disintegration of that previous
personality into a chaotic state,
prime prior to rebirth now what happens
in Pinocchio,
which by the way was released at about
the same time that World War Two was was
brewing and which also contains one of
the best representations of of the of
the individual motivations for fascism
that I've ever seen anywhere.
That's the scenes that are associated
with pleasure island.
Remember all the.
The puppet is trying to become a real
boy,
right?
So he's a Marionette to begin with,
something else is pulling his strings
well for you.
That's your habitual state of being.
Something else is pulling your strings.
Even the idea that you're autonomous is
the consequence of something else
pulling your strings and for you.
What you needed to do was find out
exactly who and what is pulling your
strings and decide if that's the
direction in which you want to go,
and that's really what happens to
Pinocchio because we're going to watch
Pinocchio Part of it in the Pinocchio
Story.
He starts out as a marionette.
Now he's a Marionette,
made by a good father because Japan was
a good father.
He's a good craftsman and so on.
So he's a marionette with a benevolent
puppeteer.
But as soon as he developed some
autonomy,
then he becomes pray to forces that are
elements of the demonic archetype.
In fact,
the worst bad guy in the entire movie
turns into Satan himself at one point in
the movie,
basically has horns in a bright red face
and he manifests himself as so
terrifying that the coyote,
coyote,
[inaudible] Fox and the cap that are
trying to corrupt Pinocchio or terrified
because they get like they're criminals.
They're petty criminals and deceptive
and so forth.
But when they get a look at who's
pulling their strings,
it's enough to terrify them.
And so Pinocchio goes through a series
of temptations of various sorts,
including authority and,
and the Freudian temptation is to remain
weak and sickly instead of becoming a
real person.
So it's an eternal problem.
And another problem that faces Pinocchio
is that he's offered false celebrity as
a way of solving his life's problems.
So he's offered the opportunity to
become an actor.
And what that means is a deceitful fake
who's constructed a persona that makes
him appear far more valuable than he
really is.
So the movie outlines to pathological
modes of movement towards maturity,
one being a phony and the other taking
the easy way out,
and the and hyper are valuing all your
pathology so that you become dependent.
So anyways,
and then another mode of pathological
development is offered to Pinocchio,
which is to do nothing but engage in
short term,
impulsive and destructive play.
And that's on treasure island.
But when he pleasure island,
but when he goes to pleasure island,
he finds that it's actually ruled by
demonic forces with faceless entities
who are transforming all the pleasure
seeking marionettes to braying donkeys
who are slaves like.
So Pinocchio escapes from that end.
He does it basically by jumping into the
unknown.
And that's where we're going to start
our exposure to his initiation.
Okay,
so now you can imagine what's happened
is he was on pleasure island and
everything went to hell fundamentally.
And so he jumped into the water to
escape from that.
That's equivalent to plunging into
chaos.
And Chaos was an escape from
pathological tyranny and now he's trying
to go home.
So this is the psyche in it's searched
for maturation,
runs into an obstacle which is the
tyrannical element of the great father
that it cannot cope with and it trucks
home runs,
hope to defeat typical part of a hero's
story is the initial defeat of the hero
when he
encounters usually either the terrible
great father or the terrible great
mother,
so and so.
This is a retrogressive you'll would
call this retrogressive restoration of
the persona,
so it's sort of like maybe you're a well
adapted adolescent and you live at home
and you're happy adolescent and
everything's good at home,
and then you go out to try to be an
adult and you fail,
and then when you come back home you try
to act like a happy adolescent again,
but you're not what you are in fact is
an unhappy adult.
And if you move back to the happy
adolescent mode of being,
then it's false and pathological.
You can't go home again.
Another typical motif in literature.
Now the cricket.
I can't tell you everything about this
story.
I can tell you a couple of strange
things about it.
One is that the cricket is Jimminy
Cricket,
right?
And the initials of Jimminy cricket or
RJC and Jimminy cricket was a common
Southern American
mild form of a cursing.
It's the equivalent of Jesus Christ.
And so you might think,
and of course the cricket is Pinocchio's
conscience and well,
so then you might ask yourself why in
the world would a pejorative,
mildly pejorative term for Jesus Christ
be applied to a cricket who's guiding a
puppet into the water to rescue his
father from a whale?
Why would any of that happen?
And answer to that is,
you know why,
but you can't say why you can't say why,
you know,
or what it is that you know,
but the mere fact that it makes sense
and it does is an indication from union
perspective that you're operating in an
archetipal level.
You understand this.
And so I could say,
here's an example of why the cricket is
a bug.
Well,
things bug you,
right?
We say that things bug me.
Well,
you should do something about the things
that bug you because that's your
conscience calling to you.
It's it's destiny in some sense,
manifesting itself as an unconscious
impulse that really bugs me means if you
can,
you should do something about it because
you think about it,
man.
There's a lot of things out there that
might bug you,
but lots of them don't.
But as some of them do,
well,
why do those bug you and not other
things?
Well,
that's a complicated question,
but one potential answer to it is that
there's part of your psyche that's
oriented towards further development.
Young would call that the self and
that's like the totality of everything
that you could be and it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a strange sort of entity in some
sense because it's partly potential and
it's potential that expands across time.
But the way that your potential totality
calls to you in the present is by
placing things in front of you that are
your problem and they announced
themselves as your problem and they do
that by bothering you.
So then if you pick up the task of
fixing the things that bothers you,
then you find the pathway to further
expansion of your personality.
So,
and that's what's happening with
Pinocchio now.
One of the things that's really
interesting about the Pinocchio movie
and that makes it incredibly
sophisticated,
is that despite the fact that the
cricket is a Avatar of Christ,
so to speak,
the cricket has things to learn just
like Pinocchio.
And so that's very cool because it's so
cool.
It's so sophisticated because it means
that you do have a conscience that
guides you,
but until you establish a dialogue with
it,
both you and the conscience or immature,
you have to establish a conscious dialog
with it and then interact together in a
manner that propels your development
across time.
And that'll stop you from being a
Marionette of forces that would make you
a brain donkey who does nothing but
slave away in salt mines.
So,
okay,
so Pinocchio goes home and that doesn't
work,
and that's where we're gonna.
Start here.
Okay.
So what's happened there?
Well,
many,
many things at multiple levels of
reality simultaneously.
And that's the characteristic of an
archetypal story.
So on one level,
Pinocchio's too old to go home,
he can't go home to his father because
in some sense he's already transcended
his father.
So there are things,
for example,
that your father can't help you with.
And the reason for that is that you
don't.
He doesn't know any more about the
situation than you do and he can't.
And so that's where his knowledge limits
out.
So that would be sort of on the personal
level.
And then on the trends personal level,
which would be the deeper,
deeper archetipal level.
What's happening to Pinocchio is exactly
what needs you described at the end of
the 19th century,
because remember that Japan has his
creator and now he's dead.
He's gone.
And so Pinocchio is bereft of,
of
placement,
so to speak.
He's,
his soul has been corrupted and he
doesn't know what to do about it.
And when he returns to his family home
or when he returns to his tradition,
what he finds is nothing.
Okay?
So then what happens?
Well,
this is another thing that you'll
swallow with just no problem whatsoever.
While this dove comes along that's sort
of Goldman glowing and drops a note
right in front of him.
Now you may remember,
and perhaps you don't,
but the star from which the dove comes
is a representation of the blue fairy
and the blue fairy is the positive
element of the unknown in Pinocchio
Movie.
And so what it basically is saying that
when you're despairing because your
father has died and your tradition has
nothing to offer,
that the positive element of the unknown
may provide you with a message about
where to go.
If you pay enough attention.
That would be an intuition or it would
be the automatic attraction of your
interest to a new thing by forces that
you do not understand.
So one of the real ways of coming to
grips with the idea of the act of the
unconscious is to understand that you
cannot control what you're interested
in.
And so then you might ask,
well,
if it's not you,
what is it?
And if you think about that problem long
enough,
you'll start to understand what you was
talking about because that is the way
that you can understand in your own life
that the things that direct you as a
being are not things that you
consciously choose.
In fact,
they're not even things that you can
consciously choose.
They're directed by other forces.
So anyways,
the dove drops a message in front of
Pinocchio and,
and the cricket.
Now it's the cricket that reads it.
So it's the same idea as what bugs you,
so to speak.
The cricket is an interpreter.
Okay,
so now what have we found out?
Well,
we found out that God,
the father and God the father,
the Creator are not in fact dad,
which is what needs should pronounced
but alive in some weird way,
and this horrible creature at the bottom
of the ocean.
And so what is Pinocchio decided to do?
He decides to go find them.
That's actually what you're doing at
university by the way,
for all the chaos that you experience
when you come to university and all the
uncertainty and all the doubt.
What you're trying to do is to resurrect
your dad,
father from the bottom of the ocean,
and if you do that,
you won't be a Marionette and if you
don't,
you will be.
Now,
this is very interesting because the
conscience here plays a very dichotomous
role,
so on the one hand,
Pinocchio is often ahead of his
conscience,
so to speak.
So he's taking the leading role and the
dialogue is kind of choppy and neither
of them know exactly what they're doing.
But in this situation it's very
paradoxical because you can see
Pinocchio's been half turned into bring
Jack Ass at this point.
Something you might well consider when
you remember your adolescence.
So
at this point that that the cricket,
his conscience does two things.
It warns them how horrible this is going
to be and how utterly dangerous it is.
And then at the same time it helps them
prepare and goes along with them.
And so it's quite comical.
So watch what happens here.
Okay,
so I've cut this a little bit,
but what happens in the movie is that he
goes to the bottom of the ocean and he
starts to ask about monster.
And as soon as he asked any of the fish
down there,
the denizens of the sub oceanic world
where monster ways they just run away.
And so monster,
who is he who cannot be named,
right?
And I'm sure you've encountered that in
your reading before,
right?
That's the,
that's the hallmark of
in the Harry Potter series,
right?
See now you've done it.
Yeah.
So this represents something so terrible
that it can't even be talked about.
Okay.
So what happens is Pinocchio ends up not
only at the bottom of the ocean,
but he has to go to the deepest part of
the bottom of the ocean where the most
terrible thing rests.
And so we're cutting to the point where
he does that.
So now you might ask how did Japan will
get into the whale?
And answer to that is,
it's never really made that clear in the
movie,
but I can tell you some things about
that.
Is that
okay
if you conceptualize your historical
tradition as a personality,
like a body of laws and customs?
Say
it's not.
It's dead,
right?
Because it's composed of the past and
because it's dead,
it can't come up with anything new,
so if it encounters something new,
it it stopped and that's what's happened
to Japan is that he's engulfed by this
entity that represents the absolute
unknown and he cannot figure out how to
get out,
and the reason for that is none of the
things he knows,
so none of the things that history has
produced as a body of knowledge are
sufficient to deal with the fundamental
problem.
That doesn't mean they're useless.
It just means that just like the puppet
is lost without the farther,
the farther is also lost without the
puppet,
and that's the relationship between you
and history,
your history.
When you study history,
you think while you're studying a record
of events in the past and that's not
right.
What you're studying is the
circumstances that gave rise to you as
a,
as a being,
and unless you understand your history
in every way you possibly can,
then you're an incomplete creature.
You don't know enough to move forward
in the same way your culture being
composed of dead father's,
so to speak,
can't progress without you because
you're its eyes and there's an Egyptian
story that features the God Horus,
who I've talked to you about before,
who actually resurrect his father from
the dad by giving him an I
so Japan,
I can't figure out how to get out of
this whale without help.
So he's kind of pushing up tombstones
there.
You might note,
all right,
now something very sophisticated happens
here so and I have to explain it to you
at multiple levels at the same time.
So now Japan is hungry and when the
whale opens its mouth,
a lot of fish come in.
Now,
one of the things I want you to think
about,
you can just put this in the back of
your mind,
is that one of the oldest sister,
one of the oldest symbolic
representations of Christ is a fish and
all of his followers were fishermen,
and so there's this weird relationship
between the messianic figure who's at
the base of it,
at least at the base of Christian
culture and the idea of things that are
pulled up from the depths.
Now,
here's what happens in this part of the
movie.
It's so amazing.
So Japan was looking for fish and the
reason for that is he doesn't think he
can get out of the whale,
and so he might as well have some fish
while he's while he's in there,
and so he's given up on getting out.
Now what happens is that the whale
swallows as if he's a fish,
so Pinocchio was put into the same
category as fish and it happens.
It happens to Japan a couple of times.
He Mistakes Pinocchio for a fish.
You'll see.
So what that means in some senses that
you pedo can't distinguish between the
fish.
That will feed you for the day and
whatever it is that Pinocchio
represents,
and so you could think about Pinocchio
as a fisherman instead of as a fish,
and so you can think about it this way.
And here,
here's a.
here's a,
an old saying,
if you give a man a fish,
you feed him for one day,
but if you teach him to fish,
you feed him forever.
And so the idea is it's better to
develop the skill to acquire something
than it is to have the thing.
Now,
what Pinocchio represents is
he's like a mega fish.
I know this is a strange way of thinking
about it.
Japan was problem,
isn't that he's hungry.
His problem is that he can't get out of
the whale and so what he's fishing for
isn't something to eat.
It's something that will help them get
out of the whale,
but he can't recognize the difference
between the approximate solution,
which is so that he'll no longer be
hungry.
So he's got a very short term outlook
and a solution to the much broader
problems.
So what happens is the whale swallows a
bunch of fish in Pinocchio's in there
and Japan was fishing away and he
catches Pinocchio and Pinocchio
Announces Himself and Japan says,
tells them to be quiet because he's
interfering with him fishing.
And then when he turns to Hug Pinocchio
because he wakes up,
he actually hugs a fish and then he
discards the fish.
So then he figures out the Pinocchios
there.
Then Japan,
oh,
decides that.
Well,
they're going to have to live inside the
whale and it's another I idea of his
blindness at this point because he's.
He's composed of the dead past so to
speak.
So what Pinocchio does it start to
destroy the ship itself,
which is what they're floating in and
the whale to start a fire and the fire
makes the whale mad enough to spit them
out.
And the whale then transforms itself
into a dragon and tries to kill them
because it's a fire breathing entity at
that point.
And so part of the understory is it's
better to figure out how to fish than to
fish or that more profoundly,
it's better to figure out how to do
something than to merely benefit from
the thing itself.
Pinocchio represents that which can do
new things.
So he's a hero and he's willing to
destroy part of the current order that's
the ship in order to produce a new
strategy that will actually free them
from the way out.
Now he wants to get his farther out of
there too.
So that's what happens in the next five
minutes,
I would say.
Come down here.
Okay.
So now there's a shark here because
essentially in some sense the entity
that's going to provide the solution to
this very complex problem has arrived on
the scene,
but it's quite damaged.
First of all,
it's been speaking improperly,
right?
So that's an adolescent representation.
So it braise a lot of nonsense and it's
been corrupted in a variety of ways.
And so you know,
to to some degree,
what that means is that as you mature
and you're moving away from your mere
marionette status,
your interaction with society like Russo
said,
corrupts you in all sorts of ways.
I mean you're participating in that
corruption,
but it still happens.
But in the representation in the movie,
the truth of the matter is,
is doesn't matter if you've been
corrupted to some degree,
as long as you have an absolutely
sacrificed to your capacity for true
speech and vision.
So you know that's a pretty hopeful
message because Pinocchio is by no means
a perfect entity,
but he might be good enough.
See,
that's also an indication there of white
people are often unwilling to form of
representation with a so to speak form a
relationship with the archetype of the
great father because to some degree the
archetype is a figure of perfection.
And the individual in relationship to
that archetype is always pathologically
flawed.
And so the embarrassment of that
realization,
which is exactly what's happening to
Pinocchio Right now,
is often enough to stop people from
doing it.
So what,
what that would say to say what that
means in some sense is that in order for
you to mature in the fullest possible
manner,
you have to understand the manner in
which you're deeply flawed in
relationship to the,
to your,
your potential as it might be
historically determined.
And that's a very bitter thing to do.
You know,
it's much easier and people do this all
the time to engage in half witted
formulaic,
ideological criticisms of the system as
a whole.
It's like,
you know,
the probability that the system is more
flawed than you is pretty damn low.
So you want to start with,
you know,
getting rid of your donkey ears in your
tail and stopped bringing nonsense
before you judge the entire,
you know,
historical process by which human beings
have come into being.
So anyways,
that's kind of what that means.
What do you
eat
when you eat
it?
Whole Pinocchio.
Okay.
So this is very interesting too because.
So Pinocchio ends up being a master of
fire.
While you can think about that as there
was a book written awhile back by a
primatologist who also wrote demonic
males,
Richard rang him and he talked about the
origin of fire and as far as Wrangham is
concerned,
we invented fire about 2 million years
ago and that enabled us to cook food and
that enabled us to swap intestinal
length for brain.
So if you look at a chimpanzee,
chimpanzees are like the ultimate in
couch potatoes,
right?
They're,
they're,
they're about this high and they're
shaped like this.
They have this huge barrel body and the
reason they have that is because they
eat leaves and so they have to spend
like eight hours a day eating leaves.
They will eat meat if they can get it.
They have to spend like eight hours a
day eating leaves and just chewing them
over and over because like leaves a.
They don't want to be eating,
so they're pretty tough than inedible
and B,
they don't have any new tricks.
Nutritive quality,
just speak up.
So the chimpanzee has to spend all of
its time chewing,
which is rather mindless endeavor.
All things considered.
Whereas human beings 2 million years ago
or thereabouts,
invented fire and as a consequence of
that,
we could cook meat and meat is
incredibly energy rich and so and it's
easy to digest once it's cooked and so
the consequence of the invention of fire
was that were the way we are today.
We could have a brain instead of a gut.
And so the idea that Pinocchio's mastery
of fire,
and it's as something more than merely a
means of cooking.
That's how it started out.
Right?
But you can think of our entire
technological capacity as stemming from
the mastery of fire.
Now the other thing you can think of,
and this is very much worth considering,
is that Pinocchio Masters Fire and that
turns the whale into a dragon.
And so the idea there too is that,
and this is an old idea,
is that our technological prowess is
something that makes nature itself
angry.
And of course you might say,
well,
do you believe this?
And the answer to that is,
well,
how many of you have environmentalist
leanings?
And that's exactly the story that you're
following you,
because you're still wondering about
whether not mastery of fire was in
somehow against the natural order and
then it will end up in all of our depths
and you know that's a reasonable thing
to worry about,
but not mastering it was going to end up
pretty badly too.
So
sense.
So here,
what happens is that in the midst of
this complete chaos,
Pinocchio has a choice and the choices
you can either save themselves,
which is a very,
very selfish choice and reduces him to
an Aa historical individual because he
has no relationship left with his father
or he can put himself at great risk and
rescue his father.
No,
finish the process.
Stop his father from drowning and
complete the story.
Okay,
so
Pinocchio Dies and then his father
brings him home.
And so because he's rescued is farther,
the benevolent spirit of nature appears.
Resurrect him and turns them into a real
human being.
So it's pretty funny as far as I'm
concerned that the answer to Nietzsche's
Greek question manifested itself in
Nineteen,
mid 19 thirties in the forms of a Gnat
form of an animated child's movie.
So you know,
and that's an,
that's an example.
That's an example of a number of things,
an example of how archetypes work.
It's also an example of how artists are
on the edge of discovery all the time
and they discover things they don't even
understand.
So we'll see you next Tuesday.